buddy so thanks again for allianz and
but you helped bring me here so good to
be here quick word to mention I I came
down with a cold this morning so if i
stop for a second in the middle to drink
some water bear with me and if I'm not
talking too loud tell me if you can't
hear me let's do this rather informal or
interactive so I'll show something about
our mission statement in the lab and our
vision why we do what we do if you have
any comments or questions while I talk
feel free to raise your hand and might
be better than doing it at the end after
all the projects because we're covering
quite a wide gamut of topics here I
guess I should think the provost for
making a segue into smart cities
unplanned segue but meet a little bit
recap and why this is an interesting
thing what's going on with cities today
so these are numbers most of us might
have already just to repeat why our
cities interesting what's going on there
now we're looking at places that cover
more than 2% of the Earth's inhabitable
crust that's it between two and two
point five so very little surface area
you got over fifty percent of the
population worldwide living in city the
trip in cities the trend is upwards big
time so there's massive urbanization
going on more than 75 percent of
energy's is consumed in city or indices
in the infrastructure that services
cities and more than eighty percent of
co2 or co2 equivalent emissions happen
there these are just four numbers that
are interesting but there are so many
other interesting statistics about
efficiencies economies of scale super
linear scaling for innovation and other
stuff so cities seem to be efficient yet
there are many many problems there in
living there if you can address some of
those issues that we're talking about
here you're touching on some of the core
problems of the planet right there the
problems of cities if we all move there
our convert
merging with the bigger problems of the
planet today now at the same time we're
seeing technology becoming small it's
connected people in a new way right we
probably all have one of those in our
pocket and then machines begin to talk
to each other as well right so this is
just an example of a modem that connects
machines to other machines people talk
to people people talk two machines
people talk to infrastructure our
environment becomes empowered by some
digital capacity and everything almost
starts to talk back to us so there's a
lot we can see about what's going on
around us in real time because of this
new type of connectivity or digital
empowerment or whatever everyday objects
I'll give you some examples a little bit
now we've all seen what happened with
the mobile market recently but this is
something slightly different in this is
a prediction by ericsson others had
similar numbers they they are saying
that by 2020 we're going to see 50
billion devices online that's extreme
right because the Internet today is
empowered by what 1 billion servers or
so we are what 7 billion people on the
planet this is an order of magnitude
more it really means that our
environment is going to be empowered by
an unprecedented number of digital
channels and in this case for example it
probably means that we're going to need
new ways both of analyzing data but more
importantly of bringing this data back
to us so we can make decisions and
actually make it actionable because if
there are so many sources of data and
and and the volume is going to be as big
as it is expected design is going to
become central to actually harnessing
the potential of this thing so at the
lab what we're doing is we're looking at
these changes in technology the cloud is
another example for what's going on with
our capacity to analyze data has
increased a lot we're asking you know is
there a new type of planning that's
arising from all of this is there a new
kind of relationship between people and
the environment we live in mediated by
small and distributed technologies we've
done this with sorry about this we're
doing this with industry
and cities and we're looking at creating
these almost like engineering feedback
loops in cities so you know many of us
have seen what's happened say to
mechanization in in a previous century
where we created control feedback loops
with sensing with intelligence so small
computers taking sensor information and
then feeding back into the system to say
alright maybe if it's a motor say open a
valve Oh close a valve you know if it's
a bigger system trying to manage
resources in the right way based on some
sensor reading what's the parallel of
this in a city it's becoming possible
because as we said everything in our
environment talks back to us we have
great way of processing that information
now how do you make the city change how
would you actually take those
observations you make or some of the
knowledge a computer might extract by
analyzing data and actuate the city and
its see there is a bit of a problem
there because if a bus comes and you
know and you want to enable traffic to
to flow more freely you kind of just
widened why's that is the street the
city has a lot of inertia it's heavy so
it seems like beyond what you can do
with infrastructure you know like
traffic lights and and the smart grid
the main thing that would impact how a
city functions is the decisions that
each and every one of us makes as we use
consume interact with our environment so
in a sense the person the individual is
the ultimate actuator of the city and
that's where I think it really comes
really interesting so if we think about
that feedback loop of sensing and
actuated it's always interesting to
think what happens when you put that the
person in the middle of that feedback
loop okay so you have some sensor in
your environment that tells you
something about air quality you mash it
up with some map okay it's one thing to
give it back to the infrastructure so
that it's managed more efficiently from
the top down another thing is to keep
everybody in the loop so that they can
make smart decisions and as they use the
city I'll show you some examples about
this in a second so again we're
partnering with the with cities and
industries to explore this possible
future around the world
we've worked with places from Amsterdam
Copenhagen London Florence and other
cities in Europe now we're working in
Singapore starting with Jakarta there's
a new project in Rio we've worked here
with this city in New York Seattle not
yet in Africa but we're working on at
the moment some examples of our projects
real-time rome this is a partnership we
did with telecom italia a lot of French
people in the room right it's going to
be a bit of a problem for me okay
there's at least there's some Italians
as well this was okay very good okay so
you know in a second why here we
partnered with telecom italia with
attack the bus service provider in aroma
and with with the taxi company called
Samuel kanda and the main point of this
was to create a map full scale of the
city that looks at mobility in real time
so suddenly with you know if everything
starts talking back to us in our
environment we can create real-time
dynamic maps and we were focusing on
mobility we got a room to show this at
the venice biennale in 2006 it's the
centerpiece here the six maps we're
using information that we processed on
our servers at MIT and then sent in real
time to get visualized at the Biennale
now we're lucky that that year france
and italy were playing the world cup
finals so it cat we captured that
information on our servers and here we
visualized very very simple data is how
many megabytes are consumed on a cell
phone tower when italians watch their
team wins or about that against france
in the world cup finals now look at this
it's quite interesting this is just
bandwidth consumption on each cell phone
tower interpolated and spread out over
the city here you know downtown people
gathered there are a lot of bars and
cafes where people could spend to spend
time to watch the game the game starts
at seven forty-five alright 745 to
silence all right nobody talks it's 102
friends
and it's 11 it's tied and a half time
people make a quick call and then second
half still 11 is great tension end of
normal time still 11 first overtime
second overtime then Sudan gives the
head butt and everybody goes crazy and
any till he wins and people stay up till
like two thirty in the morning
celebrating and the next day the winning
team came from Germany where they
gathered here and walked in a parade to
utica Massimo down here to celebrate and
okay this is you know beyond beyond the
beyond the funny context this is
interesting a one hand because we could
we could see that it captures easily the
emotions that people had around the game
you can really see what people are under
tension when people are celebrating and
expressing themselves but can we do
something more quantitative with this so
we're wondering first this was one of
the first projects we did with cell
phone data and it's not it's not
straightforward for example if you want
to count people right because people
disappear for 45 minutes when nobody
talks but we know they're all still
there and you know look looking at the
game but if you just do some very basic
signal processing you can capture very
salient features so there are dominant
features and have to do with how we use
cell phones and what we physically do at
the same time for example now we're here
most of you are not on the phone when is
you know when this will end you'll
probably send it via small text or make
a phone call it turns out that there's
some relationship between how we use the
phone and activities we engage in this
is all just bandwidth consumption it's
very aggregated right so its data that's
very easy to use it's almost it's almost
like junk that's running on the cell
phone networks that they use in order to
manage their own capacity but today we
can harness this almost to become like a
spread out sensor throughout the city
that gives us additional types of
information if we think about that
pattern we saw like 45 minutes of
silence 15 minutes of talking another 45
minutes of silence that's very
indicative of watching football all
right but maybe that's
the most interesting application but it
turns out if you cluster the city with
the same signal processing technique
it's just eigen vector decomposition for
those of you who do know a bit of signal
processing you can find out where people
sleep where people work or people get
retail space service when people get
other types of service in cities as in
the cities of today that are aiming to
become more and more let's say multi-use
we're planning is trying to stack
activities one on top of the other sort
of as opposed to what we did with a you
know 19th so with the 20th century
cities where you know people lived one
in one place and came to work in another
part of town and to party in a totally
different part of town today we're
trying to densify them to use space in a
more efficient way these become tools to
actually understand how we need space
especially because you can differentiate
between activities in real time with
very non-invasive methods so we're
thinking about this almost like a
real-time census this is a slightly more
sophisticated thing we did with the data
where we put a little threshold of
acceleration on the cell phones looking
at cell phone data and identify what
what could be likely locations of
pedestrians and these yellow things are
the buses in Rome and then we're asking
ok so if you know where the people are
and when the buses are in real time can
we make a system where the bus has
changed the people instead of the people
change the buses that was sort of an eye
in a simplified way turns out that if
you let a computer sort of look at this
problem over a few days you see patterns
and how we move around as people and
that could give rise to the design of
the of the bus route network right and
then if you see in real time that I mean
turns out we're much more boring than
with than we think three times I think
three places on average is what people
visit in a week for the most part so you
where we go is dominated by three places
every week and then our times the times
that we go out of the ordinary if you
can see that and you can plan for what
extra capacity you want on you
a bus network to respond to those
moments when we are when we aren't
expected this is something we did here
in New York with AT&T we were looking at
a much larger scale in this case this
was in the in collaboration with saskia
sassen who is here actually at Columbia
and with with several other people like
Bill Mitchell at MIT and we're asking
okay if if urban economics is claiming
that much of the global economy is
driven by cities not necessarily but
trade between countries can you use can
you observe some of these activities by
looking at telecommunication data so
from AT&T we got data about the IP
backbone activity between new york and
200 global cities around the world and
each of those things represents a link
between New York in another city these
these these blobs represent the
intensity of the interaction with New
York here you see where Europe waking up
you know all the usual suspects and this
is the Sun coming up and South America
Santiago and Sao Paulo Mexico City Asia
is sort of going to sleep
and what it turned out is that by
looking at those patterns and especially
the time series patterns you can figure
out a lot about the comp the commercial
activity between new york and other main
trade partners it also captures some
something about immigration excuse me
for one second I need some tissue 64
it's okay I'll grab a napkin here okay
hello again so now you can zoom in under
this
this is New York this is incoming and
outgoing calls on a neighborhood level
in the city now I don't know how many of
you know flushing this is a two hundred
country long list that showed us who
calls to flushing and where do people in
flushing call to just landline calls and
cell phone calls it picks up immigration
population live very very detailed way
this the sample size is several hundred
thousand calls a week and and then the
number of countries is very very the
list is very long and you get it you can
get this in real time so you know if you
think about the census which happens
every ten years doesn't always capture
immigration I think last decade New York
grew by ten percent and the vast
majority of this growth came from
immigration so if this is what the city
planner is trying to respond to for
example they could very much use
something like a real-time census which
could capture demographic composition in
such a way same goes for I don't know
what happened here so about that it
depends it depends look in general in
these projects we didn't use any
personal information right so here
you're looking at the neighborhood block
this one is about one kilometer by one
kilometer and we're looking and we're
sampling this from the IP backbone so by
looking at packets there's no way you
can tell if it's your packet or his
pocket this was our choice clearly you
can take individual information and put
it out there and expose what people are
doing if you took you know my google
search my email that Google is reading
today my photos that are searchable and
will stay alive forever all these you
can create a pretty detailed picture of
me I don't think there's anything
fundamentally different with what we're
looking at right now we've been doing
these kind of things since I don't know
probably since we've accepted credit
cards into our lives and we're willing
to give up privacy for a service I think
there's a whole new discussion about the
value of data now if the value of data
and you know we're starting with credit
cards was for my personal sphere I'll
get some some extra convenience by
giving up some privacy and you know the
same is with with with the third
and free email and things like that what
is what is the benefit of this for the
public good beyond a personal sphere you
know do people know that if they share a
bit of anonymous data may be traffic in
their street can run faster and air can
be cleaner and things like that and
you're planning can become better
whether it's in real time or in the long
term there's a new value proposition if
you want to call it for using data and I
think this is really the interesting
discussion we should engage with now
with politicians with with with with
with the utilities with the general
public to say okay so what's at stake
what can we do this privacy is a very
important part of the discussion I think
we need to understand what's at stake in
order to understand really what what's
the risk and what's the benefit of
sharing data in one way or another so
real-time census using cell phones so
are using communication information
again here we're sampling large networks
to try to understand what can we do with
the data that's flowing through them how
can we r EU ttle eyes it for some new
purpose in this case we wanted to focus
on sorry on user-generated content so
this is a project that we showed at the
barcelona design museum back in 2008
we're capturing user-generated content
some you know information people freely
upload on the internet for everybody to
see in this case it was flickr photos
we've done this later with tweets and
with other stuff but often when people
upload their Flickr photos their GPS
tagged automatically with their iphone
or by their other smartphone or even
cameras do that today and they also say
well you know what they were doing when
they took that photo we just captured
those tags and the photos and use them
instead of to create a description of
what the people were doing the Creator
description of what's going on in a
place that people were at so we call
this project a los ojos del mundo so
it's almost like borrowing everybody's
eyes to create a description of what's
happening in a place the other heat map
is activity here or just asking where
the parties in Barcelona just as a joke
right but everywhere
I know every you know what it turns out
it's everywhere where you have Brits the
girls good but uh I mean it might seem
like a funny question but it's not a
very easy question ask if you thought
about this how would you do this
traditionally if you had to ask where
the parties in person it's not simple to
know this is something a bit more
sophisticated we did Spain has a big
problem of drought every year drought
enters from east to west and it's good
quite a link white an intricate pattern
house summer enters and how it impacts
water supplies in in the country what we
did here is we took everybody's photos
and these are ten thousand or so a week
per city and we we asked which with very
basic image processing we asked where is
you know what's the intensity of the
color green was the intensity of the
color brown and we basically observed
ground so you have green clear into
brown as the summer enters going from
east to west I just by looking at the
images automatically so this becomes
almost like a way to to look at the
place through everybody's eyes when we
ask you know what's the color of the
environment around in order to
understand how drought spreads so
user-generated content as a way to
collectively describe what's happening
in place here we wanted to focus on
something where we instrument
environment ourselves so there's this
dream that everybody's been talking
about for a while called smart dust
these small digital stuff that we could
throw into the environment and would
somehow rearrange itself and communicate
we're not quite there yet it's more like
smart bricks maybe at the moment but we
wanted to apply that vision into one of
our bigger most pressing problems today
which is waste think about supply chains
this is a map done by guy called Leo
banani at the Media Lab he took a
machine like mine open it up scan what's
inside and with very little web look up
could produce this global map of how
things came together to bring this
machine to our office at MIT now look
how complicated it is so it starts with
the production of different parts and
assembly rooms and different as stalking
areas and the transportation that alot
of that it's it's it's quite amazing how
we've made supply chains on a global
scale efficient over the past 30 years a
lot of it is using digitization in order
to synchronize processes when we throw
things away we have some believe they're
taking care of right there's not nearly
as much information or control over what
happens to things when we throw them
away so what we did is we we said ok
let's let's tag garbage we developed
this sensor this thing that thing was
the first one we did it's about that big
the last one we did was that small and
basically you charge it once and it
works for a year will tell you anywhere
in the world where it is like a strip
down cell phone and this is the second
iteration of the sensor we developed
with Qualcomm and then we partner with
waste management is one of the bigger
waste removal companies globally and we
invited five hundred households in
Seattle to collect trash based on a list
we developed with a recycling
statistician and came to their homes and
help them tag this trash with those
sensors this is in the public library we
focused on Seattle Seattle is one of the
more advanced waste removal systems in
this country and our team went and
tagged I think a total of three thousand
items of trash anything from a rotten
banana to a fridge this is me here
operating on a teddy bear and
and some examples of the stuff we tagged
and this is after we threw it away now
after we left their people's places we
asked them to throw it away as if we
were never there so the point was to see
where do things go from from the bin at
home or the curbside and to its resting
place processing place landfill
recycling facility and as soon as people
threw something away they got a
real-time map which told them word or a
piece of trash really is and after
everything came to rest several months
later we had we developed this map which
shows us were things in it up so here
take a look this is a day of the
deployment at the Seattle region these
are landfills in Oregon Vancouver where
stuff went to Asia from this is us is
this is Florida here Southern California
Chicago electronic waste it turns out
traveled quite a bit in order to get
recycled sometimes up to 6,000
kilometers in travel here printer
cartridges tend to go to Southern
California but sometimes via Chicago
from Seattle so in a sense this kind of
macro picture of the waste removal chain
for electronics who's not evident before
just because there are so many
subcontractors there and there are so
many reasons for how this thing is
shaped starting from incentives that
states give to create one facility
versus another facility so if you have
you know a next volume of cell phones to
recycle and in the state next door has a
cell phone recycling facility why
recycle at home you can ship it there so
turned out that the things you learn to
recycle over the past 30 years the
things that are at high volume like
plastic glass metals paper we're
recycled within two days in the
proximity of where they were picked up
but these things we're still learning
how to treat them it's not very obvious
they're much more complicated in terms
of
they're higher value but they're more
polluting as well so that's one of the
things we've learned there but on this
an individual scale we were asking well
if I knew that this thing I threw away
say two days ago is sitting on a hill
somewhere not far how could it create
some increase awareness in terms of
personal thank you so one thing is the
macro scale to ask are there
inefficiencies can we do something
better the other thing is really looking
at the personal dimension now this thing
is showing it moma right now with we
call it back talk it's part of an
exhibition called talk to me bye bye
Paul Antonelli and so if you're there
during your visit here this is on the
third floor I believe of the museum and
we coupled the what you saw earlier but
they're now about the movement of cell
phones from Seattle to the rest of the
US as they get recycled with the second
part of the project that we did just for
moma which is to see how donated
electronics are used around the world so
what is the second life of electronics
whether it goes to recycling or whether
it goes for reuse all by instrumenting
these machines with different software
that could see where it is who's using
it what's going on in its environment
and with the consent of the new owners
that receive those machines we actually
send back pictures of how and where
they're being used so you get these
doing this is from Kolkata and all these
pictures are sent in real time to oma's
if you go there you'll see how people
use machine donated machines from the us
everywhere in the world and I think
they're like 14 different countries
they're being represented all in real
time a maybe quick note and why we and
why we show things in museums might not
seem obvious so for every project that
we do we have one component that we call
say the urban demo or the urban
experiment and there we first start with
a brief or with the vision so asking how
can technology help us solve a
fundamental problem in the city or queer
made a fundamental new experience we
partner with the city and with a with
with the with a member of the industry
that you know give context to this your
funding but then and we look at how what
type of engineering or science or design
needs to be need to come together be
developed in order to make that happen
in order to make that vision happen and
that's where we we do our more
traditional academic work in terms of
publication patenting etc so one hand is
the is is the research and and let's say
fundamental scientific questions that
can be asked when we collect data when
we you know present a new type of
technological intervention in the place
and the other thing is what we call an
urban demo which is where we actually
get feedback from cities from industry
from the general public about a
proposition we're making or a new type
of possibility we have for living with
technology so we always try to follow
those two paths at the same time it's a
project we distance F in in Paris we
were just about to launch it on their
ticket selling a mobile app they asked
us when we partnered last year how can
we work together to explain to people
the environmental impact of different
modes of transport so we took all the
sensors that we could put our hands on
inside the phone so most smartphones
that they have accelerometers of GPS the
microphone some of them have a calm past
and look recorded all their patterns
everything that that that is recorded on
through those sensors when we move
around and again by basic signal
processing we could correlate the
combination of signals that are recorded
on those sensors and the mode of
transport that one person might be
moving in and then we assign a co2
emission value to it so basically what
you have is an art is an automated
automatic care system to figure out how
you're moving by foot by car bye bye bye
bye
we could differentiate all of those
automatically and then you'll get some
feedback about the co2 emission value of
that mode of transport again for the
purpose of helping people make more
informed choices so this is something
that we're just going to launch soon
it's been developed now at our lab it
works on that on a mobile phone now they
need to scale it up make it robust and
hopefully let let their users play with
it I'm going to go quickly through this
if we think about again is a the idea of
the city as a control as a control
feedback loop we've seen a lot that has
to do with sensing right so networks can
tell us many interesting things
user-generated content can reveal
something about dynamics in cities and
you can instrument your environment with
sensors so but there are many options
for understanding what's going on
processing this information now the
question is really how do we close that
feedback loop so i want to show some
example about what you might refer to as
you know more the actuation actuation
side of that control feedback loop or
center of sensing and actuated in cities
this was done with the mayor of Florence
and starting two years ago the focus was
on really weaving real-time information
into the city and we were focusing on
urban furniture we decided specifically
to focus on the bus stop and think about
all this information we looked at
earlier you know information about the
location of public transport vehicles
congestion location of people all of
that could really be blended and
presented in a piece of let's say
augmented urban furniture seems like a
good place to start in terms of bringing
information back into the city in real
time this was our first instance of the
designs of the bus pole this is
photovoltaic cell this is a reflective
ink display and a higher resolution
interactive display computer is stuck
into that slab
this is the interaction that we've
designed for the large scale of display
basically from far away you can see
whether you need to water to run to
catch the bus to trying to catch to walk
or if you have time for coffee
large-scale something that would would
explain what's going on from far away if
you want to plan your route as you
approach the bus stop all you need to do
is to touch where you want to go right
the bus stop doesn't move so it knows
where it is so it just queries the
database and and tells you what's the
easiest way of getting to where you want
to get how long it's going to take you
give you some environmental information
about the again the choices that you're
making there you know if it's by train
and bus by bus and bus and if you're
going to be late to where you need to
get to it you could also recessed you to
take a taxi and so this is just an
example of how you can use something
that's oh that's been available for
almost a decade this type of information
but just the idea of bringing it into
the city in a way that is designed could
help could help make an impact and
improve you know the experience of
moving around with public transport
tourism information can be put on the
bus you can do is a digital billboard
and graffiti with your fingers all sorts
of stuff for the community to play with
in their neighborhood this is the
shelter again this this information
ribbon in the back that's the
interactive element and this is the more
passive layer of physical protection in
the front this project is looking at
again bringing information into physical
environments here asking how can you
really atomized a displays sensing and
displays so if we're looking at you know
a bus shelter is quite big you can put
sensors on it you can display with it if
if you could actually make the sensor
and a display almost one and bring it
down to a very very small size we're
asking how can you use that to make a
very flexible display something that you
can really distribute any environment we
decided to
instrument LEDs with little propellers
and I have the rearranged himself in
space and and look at that it's almost
like a three-dimensional screen it can
take any shape or form but also receive
information from a computer in real time
in ra which you would telogen what color
value to take what shape to take good
ideas for things to think about this as
a way to represent information in real
time in a place and we did really relate
to the physical environment that
displays in so you can do 2.5 d display
you can go more toward the 3d at the
moment we can only fly 50 of those
together there are many engineering
challenges but it seems to be possible
to do it especially if you can control
for the distance between between the
different helicopters seems like with a
minimum of 1 meter you can do quite well
you can you can have you can have quite
a few of those running running together
this is simulation here
alright sort of I think third to last
this is a project we're doing with
Volkswagen Audi as anybody have any
question by the way very good point i
mean i think they're what are the right
questions you know they depend which
point of view you take you know we
haven't figured out yet for example how
to make money out of this right so
industry is asking well well what's in
it for us who was it i forget Gartner
last year said four trillion dollars is
the opportunity for smart cities okay
but you still see big big blue chip or
other infrastructure managers being
reluctant to jump in I think last year
was the first time that was really heavy
funds invested in this for example with
what IBM and Cisco did IBM spent forget
what is it 200 and something million
dollars over the past two years on
research and and on mainly on marketing
on this idea of smart cities not many
products yet still we're seeing you know
the old products that have been proposed
to 10 years ago like congestion pricing
and and some smart grid solutions but
the startup world has not been waiting
for for for the big for the big guys to
move so now you're seeing new
initiatives that try to harness whatever
data is out there in order to propose
solutions for communities for urban
environments without asking any mayor or
anybody there you can do that a lot I
mean one example is a startup called
ways that is today in many cities has
the best traffic information it's
instrumenting control rooms and cities
and they're only doing this by asking
people for information for their gps
location for reports so they're really
harnessing the fact
every one of us is out there driving
probably with a smartphone to create
these very detailed maps they even
create the street maps using those GPS
traces so in places where you don't have
good maps they can correct for your maps
and that's it I think that this is a
very interesting thing so one question
is the business side of it there's a
question of governance like if you have
a startup like this that's doing say
that's helping people navigate and move
around what does it mean for the
government you know how do you how do
you make sure that there is no certain
quality of services maintained how do
you make sure that there's an equitable
distribution of of access so that seems
like a very relevant question from a
scientific standpoint that's that's what
the one place where there's been no
problem of identifying good questions
because if you think about it the social
sciences can benefit a lot from this so
far many things have been looked at
anecdotally for example with regard to
human behavior human mobility
person-to-person interaction suddenly
you have all this data putting almost
the capacity to for quantitative
analysis behind the social sciences some
people call it the quantitative social
sciences so there are there are there
are very good questions there you can go
back to some of the old questions
answered them in a new way um but I
think it's a good point it's not yet
clear where this is going there's a lot
of talk but at the moment we're not
seeing this every day in our life I
think there are many many reasons maybe
four main ones one is the question of
business the other one is a question of
you know what regulatory framework or
governance needs to happen there me you
know probably probably it means that the
governor's government is going to do
less of less operations more
incentivizing and regulation and then I
think the most important question is a
question of creating will in explaining
to the public to the mainly to the
general public why should they be
interested in this why should they want
to participate what's in it for
everybody and then their fourth one is
probably a question of Technology
there's quite a bit of progress to be
done there well I'm probably probably
missing a few other bottle
next this is something that we've been
doing with Volkswagen Audi I don't know
why it's stuck
here we were asking okay take all this
data we have about the city that tells
us where people are where events are you
know where disruption to mobility is and
try to bring it to people where they
need it again this idea of actuation and
the car seems like a really good
opportunity to close that loop so if you
know so much about what's happening and
you know so much about the driver given
the cars today are packed with sensors
right can we intersect those two the
personal profile with a profile of the
city let's time dependent and then offer
people navigation in a way that can
really support their goals and moving
around really usually usually
transportation or driving is not about
getting from place a to place B it's
about doing something so we're trying to
engage in some kind of activity and and
the idea is that if you know something
about what people are doing when they go
from one place to another place and
what's going on you can intersect it to
an offer people and much more useful
help and the analogy we wanted to take
here as we know like like a driving
companion what happens say when you
drive with your friend or with your
partner next to you and they have the
bandwidth actually look around and tell
you it's it's it's congested down there
make a right or make a phone call to ask
what's going on in another part of town
or think where you know at times when
you need to be concentrated but can we
emulate this electronically can we
create the digital driving companion
something that can know what's going on
far away from the car in real time
something that something that knows you
and can it knows what you are looking
for and interested in and can really
make subtle propositions so this is this
is a system we developed for indexing
the city actually this is a screenshot
from the from the working system that
was year one of the project we were just
grabbing information from the internet
from event listings like upcoming org
they have ten thousand events a week in
Boston and we took information from
sprint and verizon about where I think
with 1.1 million people aggregated are
moving around in the city to create some
sort of a understanding of the intensity
of mobility from place to place we're
looking at points of interest so
basically there is a system it's almost
like Google who's indexing the city
constantly to see what's going on there
second part of the project was profiling
the driver and then offering an
interface you're going to laugh when you
see that interface because it's really
it's at the moment it's a bit grotesque
but but think of a thing of this is the
starting point something right now that
that would that would get toned down in
order to present an immersive
environment and navigation inside the
car what we wanted to do there is take
that data we're talking about and sort
of bring it into the car almost like you
know extending the three-dimensional
view of the city that you have through
the windshield on to your dashboard and
letting you interact with it via
gestures right so at the moment it looks
a little bit distracting I understand
but think about this as a beginning of
an exploration that once we understand
what really is important what's not
important from a design standpoint we
get to keep those essential parts and
and try to see how you can how you can
really blend dynamic information into
your dashboard about what's going on in
the city and how to move around sure
sure
yeah I mean I I think we're starting to
see data about traffic it's not good yet
in that you know if you I i I've I've
only looked at Google Transit carefully
I don't know don't don't what enough and
ways data and in Rick's data in Turks is
the biggest agency I think here in the
States it's good for the fun something
funny about how they how they presented
they say it's ninety percent accurate
which is true it's ninety percent
accurate but you could predict traffic
to ninety percent accuracy as well and
you know that between eight to nine you
know that's where most rooms a
congestion happens you want to know
those you know if you really need that
pale and when the little interventions
little disruptions can make can make you
ride three times as long sometimes are
you seeing in the city sometimes
crossing from east to west takes you
forever and it's because you know a
truck is unloading something in a street
corner that's the hard stuff to pick up
it will divert you off the m25 put you
on a carriage way inside the m25 avoid
the traffic jam
you're asking III don't know about them
specifically but I think really that one
what you're describing here is really
looking at probably they're getting some
sort of data from the transportation
agencies about disruptions about and
usually on the large-scale you see this
happening in highways because highways
are instrumented with a lot of sensors
already even the toll booths can tell
you something about the volume of
traffic sorry but really which if which
if you're trying to see something on
their first of all on the on the on the
small artery level second of all if
you're trying to couple this with
information about the city itself it's
not so much about where traffic is
that's the first thing probably most
crucial one but then you know what is
there to do what is going on beyond
traffic events traffic related events
that's something that we haven't yet
seen happening I think not so much
because it's there's no ability or no
access to such data it didn't I don't
think it's on the mind of the Tom terms
of the world but now that navigation is
becoming so much more than just
wayfinding I think we will begin to see
this more and more and more the big
question is in terms of design I think
that navigating with an iphone when
you're driving is awful rocky it's crazy
when you it's so dangerous and really I
mean even the tom-toms there a little
bit distracting me what the one you put
on the side of the screen but that's all
that's that's that's somewhat okay at
least you don't need to look down it's
too small it's not the right scale it's
too intense in terms of the amount of
information you're trying to do to
communicate so I think we need to
rethink this today especially when
materials become responsive and can
start to
to show information maybe the dashboard
is the best place to do this maybe not
the question is really what should be
shown and and and and how you interact
with it so it's a design it's a design
challenge we're also working on now on a
sticker that you can put on the on it on
an interactive sticker you can put on
your on your on your windscreen yeah I
think that's a very good point in a
sense that some it's a it's beginning to
happen because you know if you think
about everybody sharing data about their
location it's almost like a social
network of locations where we create
together a collective map right but when
it comes to more personal more personal
social sphere I think I think depending
on the use case I think this is a you
know you could make coordination much
more easily it could make identifying
what to do and where when you're when
you're when you're out and about if you
make scheduling of your meetings from
your phone much you know much much
easier because for example if it knows
this is a very sort of simple simple
example of something that could happen
tomorrow if you want if some if your
calendar is obvious on the phone and you
know that somebody is underway from a
play place a to place B and you know
that there is traffic down down the
street you could basically you know that
this person is going to be late to a
meeting right so the day you can make
that connect a computer can make that
connection very easily then they could
help you could either you know
reschedule your meeting or call to let
somebody know in some way become an
assistant for moving around by
communicating but by connecting your
social engagements whether it's for work
or for pleasure with you know some
information about mobile
the both on your car and within the city
I think that that intersection is
already beginning to happen if the
question is what really what's what can
we do with this that's more than just
wayfinding I just want to show quickly a
few more things this is something we did
with enal the Italian utility we started
this last year this was a five-year
project unfortunately management change
there we stopped that project after one
year now we're going to continue this
with a 22 potential partners we're
looking into working with on this the
idea was to look at they had a power
plant they were building in MO hosted
they were actually adding capacity to a
nuclear power plant one of the bigger
ones in that area in Slovakia and we
were asking how can you use sensing and
information in order to make the
operation in the construction of that
place safer they have people there from
11 different nationales 4,000 employees
on site and people die there every year
building this thing it's not rare it
happens in the mining world I'm sure it
happens you know I'm sure I'm sure in
other construction large-scale
construction sites it happens there
specifically sometimes people travel two
hours to get to work in the morning and
they get to work there already tired and
their supervisor doesn't even speak
their language so think of this as a
channel it's almost like a mini city
right you can you can take analogies
from this to moving around you know
Jackson Heights here where you know
within the space of five minutes you
cross from El Salvador 22 hey she it's a
great it's almost like a condensed urban
situation there but with critical
challenges there people would fall off
of scaffolding for nth there to that to
decide to observe what are typical
accidents and we decided to install both
the environment there with some sensors
people with smartphone applications that
would measure with indoor location where
they are to a precise level at something
that's not existing yet in terms
Villa off-the-shelf technology imagine
and the indoor version of a GPS and then
in the back end have something like a
virtual control room something that
understands scheduling so they had
accidents there for example where
somebody is using is somebody's
airbrushing for paint and somebody was
welding at the floor below you can
imagine what happens if the two meet and
you know that it's enough that one
process is delayed by a bit that
synchrony is gone schedule the initial
scheduling is not enough the question is
what's happening in reality right if I
if a painter is planned to come in at 10
they come in at 10 15 and the welder is
a little bit early etcetera you can
imagine how things can get out of
control quite easily and accidents could
happen in a place that's very
complicated 700 rooms haven't been
underground etc so instrumenting the
environment instrumenting people then
having a system in the back end of keeps
track of all scheduling the initially
planned schedule something like a
building information model that is time
enabled this is something with this is
what do we developed in year one and
then a way of bringing this information
back both to the operators or the safety
inspectors a person who is in the
control room and to the people on the in
the field so we had with one of the
first things we developed with the we
call it a geofence so with that location
information using the information from
the sensors yeah that's a good using
information from the sensors we created
an assessment of risk level and say you
were approaching an end of a and end at
the end of the scaffolding it would buzz
in your pocket that you're too close to
it on the other hand if you if you are
if you're walking in an area where now
there's an open hall a hole in the
ground we can protect you from this so
this is almost like a virtual physical
barrier we noticed there when we studied
the place that people ignore their
yellow lines on the floor quite quickly
because they don't change you know
quickly enough sometimes you need to
cross that line is still safe sometimes
you need
line needs to be farther you know if
you're blowtorching and there's gas
there you should probably be much much
much further inward whereas you know if
you're trying to fix something on a
place that's after that yellow line then
there's no choice you need to cross it
what do you do so these things need to
become dynamic people have become
desensitized in many ways to safety
instructions how can you then really
make them more contextual relevant and
bring them back to the people with their
mobile phones using real-time risk
analysis and also historical data we've
worked there with the responsive
environment group with the reason I'm
not showing too much here is that this
was here one out of five I can tell you
what was accomplished so far that
sensing environment we've instrumented a
construction site actually at MIT
because we we didn't get to the point
where it's instrumented the site in
Mojave if it was all designed based on
what we planned for most so there was
instrumentation of sensors the mobile
phone app for people and a tangible
interface basically a physical model of
the place that is empowered by digital
data something you can actually look
something where you can look at the
plant see how the construction is
progressing and safety safety level
risks were presented in visuals and you
could interact with this with with its
data with haptic devices this is from
the tangible media group at MIT so
sensing processing of information and
tangible interfaces haptic device is
like a mouse is an example but something
that could you know that you would as a
person hold or play with in order to
interact with that with with with a
computer okay this is going back to to
the city here bicycles mayor of
Copenhagen started partnership with us
in 2007 the brief we gave ourselves for
the partnership is how can we use
technology to attract more people to
biking and
we went there we started our more bikes
and people in Copenhagen it's true it's
to have one point something bikes per
person fifty percent of the trips are
done by bike the infrastructure there is
quite advanced but still if you look at
it there are limitations it tapers off
beyond a certain distance people don't
bike so much beyond a certain age people
don't bike so much when it's a pog raphy
is a bit more challenging even though
Copenhagen is quite flat people people
stop biking so we asked how can you how
can you use electronics digital
technology on a bike in order to think
of San Francisco maybe as a biking city
in order to offer some higher-level
services within a bike so we looked
around electric bikes are not there yet
I think they're bit clunky and ugly even
though it's a very growing market very
heavy it's the wrong it's the wrong
design it's the wrong thinking behind it
i think sensor enabled biker this is a
joke it's worked by a friend of ours but
they're not there yet either so what we
decided to do is take a lot of these
technologies you know a motor which is
also a generator some batteries put a
little computer all inside the back
wheel of a bike something that would
Swire less that you can stick onto any
bike and and then make it somehow smart
and hybrid this is what it looked like
the the the object we design we wanted
something that everybody we want to have
something that's almost like the the
iphone of a lack of electric bike
something sexy that's fun and and inside
it there is you know there's hybrid
capacity there's a torque sensor here
that would understand how how you output
energy and then you can tell it with
your phone make me twice as strong or
three times as strong but no throttle no
no artificial interaction with some
electronics that is different in any way
from our old experience of riding bikes
we wanted to keep it the same very very
simple just pedaling there's also a GPS
microprocessor in there for air quality
sensors there's a piece of Bluetooth
here's a little video
oh we want to be able to hear it now
that this is I'm going to try to turn it
up as much as I can
so this is something that the first the
first prototype of this was launched in
in the climate summit in Copenhagen
we've kept it we kept on developing it
last year think about this you know all
these applications are circumstantial
whether it is creating collective maps
of air quality or doing green miles is
something that mayor of Copenhagen
proposed but all the data that comes out
of this is online you can use it for
planning you can use it for you know
enterprise solutions for fleet
management it doesn't really matter the
main point is that each and every one of
us can write the software on this right
the developer a City Hall employee
company hey this is all becoming very
easy very accessible but main point is
you know you can think of LA it's
shrinking suddenly you can bike through
it you can think of Vancouver is not so
hard to climb through this is the data
that that was generated by 12 bike
messengers in the city creating
collective maps of air quality these are
back then mayor of toronto david miller
and mayor of copenhagen knew he'd be
hago david miller was ahead of c40 which
was a group of 40 cities that committed
to combat climate change irrespective of
statements decision so we know that the
day cities can do a lot to combat
climate change and just because you know
of the same number we some numbers we
saw earlier in the presentation so much
is impacted by how cities function and
that that if the mayors can take action
today without waiting for for statesmen
decisions this is what c40 set out to do
he was a big supporter of the project
today to me it's michael bloomberg has
actually taken his place in heading c40
and he liked the problem
and we didn't coordinate the color of
his scarf in the wheel the coincidence
all right when I'm going to stop here so
so rather than doing this a long Q&A
session in the middle I what we thought
of doing this more throughout the talk
so quite a few questions have already
risen but if you guys have any more
questions where I understood we have
time for two or three
well maybe I mean this is not the first
time I've heard that comment if you
think about some of the problems of
cities they are quite complex right you
need you need people from many different
disciplines many points of view to come
together to take a look at those
problems and in our lab where people at
the moment I think we have about 30 pts
and postdocs probably from 10 or 12
different disciplines from Social
Sciences through design to engineering
and this is a result of you know what
happens with so many people from so many
different the fields work together
sometimes we work in an object sometimes
it's a piece of software most of the
time it's combination you need smart
vehicles in the city need smart
infrastructure you need smarter people
smarter software you need good sensing
data you need good design in order to
bring that data back to people all these
things are important and they're all
becoming now increasingly possible
because of this kind of merger between
digital and physical stuff so we've
decided to explore as many of them as we
can it's true that for academia you know
there's a limit of how far you want to
take this this is where I we stop this
this project at some point a couple of
students are not spinning it off you
know we're not looking into scaling it
up or making it robust because that's
you know other people who are better at
this and we should probably stick to
generating ideas and then and more sort
of forward-looking vision but we're
really exploring the gamut there